[Musique]
la majorité dans cette assemblée
et sur ce dossier des retraites
minoritaire dans le pays
je dis bien minoritaires au de cet
homicide hémicycle vous n'avez pas de
majorité 61% des français demandent le
retrait de ce texte
il n'est pas trop tard pour ranger au
placard
votre réforme qui n'est ni fait ni à
faire alors qu elle déconstruit l'une
des composantes majeures dans notre
contrat social respecter la loi
respecter les français retirés enfin
cette réforme le millier de pages de
l'étude d'impact donne un nombre
considérable d'informations et le
président chassaigne et messieurs et
mesdames de l'opposition il
il lui il eût été intéressant par
exemple de comparer cette étude d'impact
dans le nombre d'informations qu'elle
donne dans la densité qu'elle représente
avec celles qui ont prévalu lors des
dernières réformes des retraites lors
des dernières réformes des retraites et
on verra monsieur le président
chassaigne que l'ensemble des données
sont sur la table et c'est tant mieux
car nous n'avons pas peur du débat
nous considérons que ce débat est
parfaitement légitime bien entendu
puisqu'il s'agit d'un débat
parlementaire mais qu'en plus il
permettra l'édification la construction
d'un texte qui constituera une
refondation de notre pacte social
l'avis du conseil d'état a été rendu il
sera évidemment pris en compte par le
gouvernement c'est à ça qu'il sert ce
n'est plus uniquement la ville de wuhan
qui est touché et bon nombre de nos
concitoyens qui travaillent ou qui sont
en vacances en chine rentre donc en
france nous pouvons distinguer deux
catégories ceux qui vont être rapatriés
par le gouvernement français et ceux qui
rentrent par leurs propres moyens
le gouvernement se veut rassurant mais
ses passagers vont pourtant arriver
partout dans l'hexagone et dans nos
outre-mer alors que trois cas ont été
détectés en france quelles mesures de
contrôle aux frontières françaises
visant ses passagers en provenance de
chine sont prévues afin d'endiguer la
programmation du virus de plus alors que
nos hôpitaux et le personnel sont à bout
d'une sur sollicitations quotidiennes
la menace d'une crise sanitaire de
grande ampleur devrait appeler de votre
part et par anticipation des moyens
exceptionnels l'essentiel de l'épidémie
reste en chine et l'ensemble des cas
signalés ont tous un lien avec la chine
le ministère des solidarités et de la
santé et change de manière régulière
avec la communauté scientifique
française
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
l'union européenne
les établissements de santé sont
préparés et la prise en charge des
premiers cas nous le prouve la situation
épidémiologique fait l'objet d'un suivi
quotidien
la stratégie que nous conduisions est
bien d'éviter la propagation du virus
cela passe par une information à
destination des professionnels de santé
et de la population
depuis le début du mandat de nombreux
événements portant atteinte aux
parlementaires ont eu lieu des
permanences ont été vandalisés des
domiciles attaqué des correspondances
insultante allant jusqu'aux beunas de
mort et même des véhicules brûlés
aujourd'hui nous sommes témoins et
victimes d'une constante augmentation
des violences dans les rapports sociaux
et les comportements de nos concitoyens
combien de collègues doivent encore être
victimes de ces faits fossiles qu'entre
d'entre nous restent à terre avant que
certains membres de l'opposition sur ses
bancs sortent de leur mutisme et
condamne fermement de tels comportements
ce combat ça n'est pas celui de l'autre
ce combat c'est celui de l'ensemble de
ceux qui croient à la démocratie la
démocratie
elle se défend et aller parfois menacés
et c'est chacun individuellement qui a
son rôle à jouer je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]